jannis und ich gehen heute in berlin
spazieren
wir zeigen euch sprüche aufkleber und
wcities die wir auf der straße rené lohs
gibt eine rauchfreie haltestelle ist
eine saubere sache dachte auch der typ
der mit der graffiti dose ins gewicht
der bvg beamten sprühte diesen spruch
unterstütze ich denn ich habe gerade
aufgehört zu rauchen
helft einander liebt einander jeden
alles jedes platz jeden lichtstrahl
vergibt die hanfparade am zwölften
august wirbt mit tollen sprüchen wie
breit da kommen wir weiter in sechs
wochen ist bundestagswahl
deshalb dürfen die partei mit
wahlwerbung auf der straße machen diese
mir unbekannte partei sagt krebs nein
danke
die möchte gesundheitsforschung
betreiben
seinen senf dazugeben ist im deutschen
eine redewendung für seine meinung sagen
burger king hätte gerne dass wir unsere
meinung hier lassen wann bekommen für
einen roboter gratis wie in fast allen
großen städten gibt es auch in berlin
eine umweltzone die umweltzone heißt
dass man mit schadstoff reichen autos
dort nicht fahren darf
hier ist die umweltzone vorbei deshalb
dort darf man wieder mit allen
autofahren treffe ist ein etwas
ruhigeres wort für gesicht oder mund
wenn man sagt halt die fresse heißt dass
man soll ruhig sein und fresse ist eine
abkürzung dafür
es ist sehr nicht so nett fresse janosch
das würde ich niemals sagen ja mist tut
mir leid tut mir leid echte weisheiten
von der straße ihr bier
das ist politik zum anfassen von der
partei die partei die genannten vier
quali als 800.000 menschen feiern beim
bierfest in berlin nur du warst nicht da
warum linke lieber alleine der hannes
trinkl überall ein
hier gibt es eine große auswahl an 47
das ist ein auch auf die gefahr hin dass
ich mich jetzt lächerlich mache aber
gibt es einen großen unterschied
zwischen verschiedenen c7 jahres
vermutlich als fehlen ich kenne ich mich
für mich ist sie gleich das ist martin
schulz der kanzlerkandidat der spd
er ist der große moment von angela
merkel sein wahlprogramm lautet martin
schulz amtieren von vielen leuten spd
wählen
dieses plakat möchte darauf aufmerksam
machen dass rücksichtslose fahrer fahrer
und möglich
oder man fährt einfach ohne rücksicht
auf seine mitmenschen dass ich also sein
wie stets im vordergrund
ich finde dieses verkannt nicht so
gelungen also unmöglich
angela merkel steht für ein deutschland
in dem wir gut und gerne neben ich auch
welt mich das hier ist der schutz des
monats jetzt nur 74 95 statt 100 euro
wenn demnächst auch den schuh des monats
sehen wollt dann folgt vor dem
schuhgeschäft auf facebook like us on
facebook facebook.com flash rannersdorf
940883 3 893 904 358 fragezeichen
rechtsgleichheit
[Musik]
[Applaus]